el truco está en considerar propiedades
de la secuencia más que buscar patrones
específicos por ejemplo podríamos
empezar contando el número de ceros y
unos que ocurren en una secuencia nos
estamos acercando pero no es suficiente
pues en ambos casos resultan similares
la solución reside en contar secuencias
de números por ejemplo secuencias de
tres números consecutivos la secuencia
que es aleatoria tiene la misma
probabilidad de incluir cualquier
secuencia de igual tamaño esta se llama
propiedad de estabilidad de la
frecuencia y se verifica en esta gráfica
uniforme la falsificación es ahora
evidente los humanos favorecemos ciertas
secuencias cuando adivinamos lo cual
resulta en el patrón disparejo que se
muestra aquí esto pasa entre otras cosas
porque consideramos que puede haber
resultados que son menos probables que
otros date cuenta no existe tal número
de la suerte no existe tal secuencia de
la suerte si echamos un volado 10 veces
tienen la misma probabilidad de ocurrir
10 águilas seguidas 10 soles seguidos o
cual en secuencia de 10 resultados